thank you very much a gorgeous night
outside so many tower camps for us here
at 80's now to go through i chose this
one
our strat cam looking at the great shot
of resorts world there
and right now we're looking at partly
cloudy skies we'll see clouds cloud up
even more as we get through the evening
hours but let's focus on the high for
the day today
not quite as warm as yesterday and we
warned you about that yesterday
but still near average 59 degrees our
high officially yesterday we were in the
low 60s
38 overnight for a low a chilly start at
least not the cold start that we saw
near freezing a few weeks back 54
degrees
in centennial hills summerlin at 50 even
aliante here at 54.
the east side coming in right now at 60
even sunrise mountain
60 also green valley henderson checking
in right now 54.
rhodes ranch mountains they had southern
highlands both at 54.
same goes for seven hills and also
anthem at this
five o'clock hour 56 currently for
boulder city you're at 53
and still in the mid 60s and nice and
comfortable
down the river in laughlin here is our
doppler network now what this does is it
picks up sweeps around
picks up any raindrops we're not seeing
anything we knew we weren't going to get
in here
we threw the satellite in there too
because you can see the clouds already
thickening up just west of us in the
night county
this will thicken even more as we get to
the evening again no showers here
all that is stuck up in the pacific
northwest we just haven't had
days and days of rain so far but we have
several systems that are pinwheeling off
the pacific however those again
will stay to the north what we will get
is occasional clouds here and there as
we get through the rest of this week
we will stay dry unfortunately but we
will cool down this weekend this is when
we start to see more
changes this weekend but only about five
to seven degree cooldown saturday and
specifically sunday but it will also be
breezy this weekend as we see these
changes
make their way in how breezy here are
your winds gusts up to 25
saturday and sunday not strong enough
for any advisories to be issued but
it'll be locally higher
around 30 if you're going to be heading
down the lake so keep that in mind if
you can do any recreation
this weekend 40 degrees overnight mostly
clear and chilly
winds will stay light for tonight winds
light tomorrow
but we'll see a mixture of sun and
clouds with thicker clouds later in the
day also for tomorrow
winds stay light and above average here
are your neighborhoods all right
centennial hills 59
sky canyon same story summerlin 58 60
mountains edge
60 north las vegas 59 for prompt along
with boulder city and laflin at 69
degrees now
seven-day forecast shows milder
temperatures as we get through friday
your weekend those changes like we
talked about in the form of wind
and cooler temperatures in those mid 50s
and then we're warming up again look at
that
mid 60s this time next week
that is your most accurate weather
update denise over to you